all right tonight more shocking violent
crime caught on tape earlier this month
a police officer in naperville illinois
was ambushed by a man with an ax
the officer made a very split decision
to shoot and kill the man likely saving
his own life take a look
all right i think it's a good picture to
send it to me
just the latest example of dangerous and
difficult decisions police officers must
make on a daily basis unfortunately
anti-police rhetoric defund dismantle
nobel is fueling more and more violent
crime all across the country for example
five major cities all run by democrats
are now on pace to pass last year's
homicide numbers in dc there have been
over 90 homicides so far this year by
the way ask yourself do you know the
names of any of them including a
teenager who was killed over the weekend
at an event called mochella but sadly
the senseless violence is now all too
common in new york one person killed
eight injured in a harlem shooting on
father's day weekend in the city of
chicago well they set the record again
47 shot over this past weekend that
included an 11 year old girl shot in the
leg and get this look at your screen
police are now searching for a suspect
after new footage shows louisville mayor
the louisville mayor being sucker
punched during an event on saturday
where are the the big city democrats who
claim to click care so much about gun
violence well you know when is joe biden
going to visit chicago because he paid
no attention to it eight years as vice
president when will he demand
accountability in this democratic-run
city in this deep blue democratic state
because this has been going on since he
first became vice president why is this
happening weekend after weekend after
weekend no solutions no no attention we
have scrolled the names of our american
treasure lost to the lawlessness in
major cities why is it democrats
continue to politicize the issue rather
than work to fix the problem why do we
only hear about the names of people
when democrats can politicize the issue
and blame republicans or blame trump and
i'll ask again where is the
investigation into the 574
riots during the summer of 2020. we had
dozens of dead americans thousands of
injured cops billions of property damage
remember it was joe biden that said
police they become the enemy and the
crime we're now seeing in major cities
is the natural consequence of all of
these bad policies that we keep pointing
out hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else